the final offensive by Iraqi forces into
West Mosul is on this is almost
certainly the most dangerous battlefield
in the world today everyone involved the
military the militants and the civilians
of course they all know Islamic state
here is made up of locals and backed by
foreign fighters including Britons but
all are keen to fight many were forced
here and as to fight intensifies they're
trying to desert for the first time a
self-confessed is member on the run from
Mosul now in Syria has spoken
he is British we know exactly who he is
he claims to have joy in Islamic state
to live under Sharia law he says he
didn't want to fight and like others for
this he was punished there's a process
of them
they go through some some more Islamic
teachings and after that they are
phoning to the phone lines there is a
sort of a reminder of why you need to
fight Todd camp mmm it's not it's not
really a reminder of why you need to
fight it's kinda like you know we need
you and we can do what we want with you
really
you know you're not in a place to say no
to us and if they fail that camp balram
didn't then there's no failing you know
there's no escaping your just you can
feel it it's no it's no test
just like a prison but the expectation
is that when they come out they will go
and and fight their thought though yeah
from the start this battle has been
characterized by suicide attacks this
was day one some are mad charges towards
troop others more sophisticated they're
often filmed by Islamic state the digger
is armored Islamic state video shows it
pushing its way past makeshift defenses
now behind Iraqi military lines in West
Mosul it drives towards the front lines
of unsuspecting troops from the rear the
driver has a very specific target and
it's where we are approaching he passes
us heading for a tank
fit-up what if you're involved with the
perpetrators of this type of thing you
are in trouble
something those now desperate to return
home except this is something you've got
you know you've got to be improved for
like at the end of the day like I'm just
trying to get my life back if it so be
it I have to go to prison in order to do
that and you know I'm prepared to do
like I said I'm not I'm not here to harm
anybody
I'm just here to look after my family
and live my life Islamic state is by no
means finished of course
Mosel isn't the final battle that there
may never be 100 grams of Sky News Iraq